all about getting up close and in depth
with all the exciting games we have in
production here at Ubisoft I'm users but
there's no time to waste
so let's head straight for the streets
of futuristic London and see what the
hackers of dedsec are getting into the
illegal painting is spreading subversive
and possible messaging over the last few
weeks of the slum Dhin are not the work
of several people as was originally
believed the work of an individual
[Applause]
[Applause]
authorities recommend not to approach
the individual first they came to the
florist and I did not speak out because
I was not a foreigner
then they came for the protesters and I
did not speak out because I was not a
protest
then they came for the journalists and I
did not speak out because I was not a
journalist
and then they came for street artists
did not speak
because I am NOT a straight artist
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now realized that eventually that come
for me and there would be no one left to
speak for me
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry
after a long night London is in
oh well well welcome to the resistance
there's a welcome gift you could tell me
it was a bloody costume party try it off
the new key suspect has been identified
as David Ford a 43 year old London taxi
driver he has no but is currently
believed to be a terrorist I'm Clint
Hocking Clint has been a longtime
creative force here at Ubisoft and now
he's bringing this vision to watchdog's
region so yeah what we just saw was an
amazing short film by the director
Alberto Miele ago that was inspired by
watchdogs Legion and looks at at the
game and the universe and the characters
through his incredible artistic vision
and visual style city needs a resistance
like the film watchdogs Legion tells the
story of ordinary heroes setting aside
their differences in order to come
together as a collective and to fight
for a positive change
you can literally recruit and play
anyone who you see in the open world
you profile people that are interesting
to you you help them with their problem
you play their Orange admission just
helped me get some closure and I'll do
everyone sounds like a dead set problem
leave it to us and that's how you
recruit them into your team and then
they become the heroes of the game and
and the stars of your story and what are
you doing in my flat
you Fabian please think more underground
I'm tickled but think more underground
what dead sick yeah right now I'm che
guevara you're done and they make the
story not only you know unique to them
but unique to you as the player and
personal to you because they're you know
heroes that you've chosen and invested
in what would I say to fans I guess I'd
say you know take care of yourselves
stay safe welcome to the resistance
our London town
a modern metropolis built on history and
prosperity only took 12,000 years to
build it up and one night to tear it all
down
oh my god
listen up you do your units to move in
and lock down the sick
with London under attack by a mysterious
terrorist the government turns to a
private military company called Albion
to keep everyone safe what could
possibly go wrong
ladies and gentlemen mr. Nigel Cass CEO
of Albion he's kindly stepped up to
establish order
[Music]
understand this I will not allow anyone
not even myself to jeopardize this he
will stop at nothing to permanently
control the city
London will be the first city in the
world to be made truly safe Nigel's not
the only opportunist who's taken a
liking to this fair city
meet Mary Kelly head of the most
powerful crime syndicate in London
eschew and spread the word
she and her goons are using the dark web
to sell everything from party pills to
people scary I know I've got to keep
tracks on my merchandise - hi you made
me a slave you do not want to ruffle her
feathers
with the city out on its ass it now
falls on you to build a resistance and
take back London any of the brave London
as you see walking the streets can be
recruited into your team like him
or even
everyone could become your next secret
weapon in our first mission we need to
get some dirt on Nigel Cass and that
means breaking into Albion headquarters
inside the Tower of London all the hardy
souls you see here are people we have
recruited from the streets of London
they all have unique abilities and
you're free to tackle this mission with
whoever you like
[Music]
like everyone in dedsec either can hack
pretty much whatever but as a
construction worker he has a particular
set of tools that make him handy
he can even call his own cargo drone
perfect for gate-crashing when you're
not invited and who needs a regular old
gun when you have a bloody male gun
[ __ ]
[Music]
perhaps we could approach this mission
differently if you'd rather keep your
distance we've got you covered
amy is a drone expert what have we here
a real tech connoisseur hate spiders but
love this one what an adorable creepy
crawler a drone expert does have the
unique ability to summon their own
drones this little darling is fast and
stealthy
I'm reading incoming drones
she could also hack enemy drones turning
the tile in her favor
and if you are not into direct
confrontation there are more ways than
one to get the job done recruiting at
Albion Officer like Brielle here might
be challenging but it'll get you inside
restricted Albion areas don't mind me
just doing VidCon for a bunch of
insurgents however do anything
suspicious and she'll probably wind up
with a bullet in the back of her head
we're missing the human element here I
can get the defense minister on the line
right now but if you feel you must
[Music]
premon ORS running our streets illegals
threatening our families the police
commissioner himself assassinated by
terrorists well that seems to be enough
evidence next up we're crashing Mary
Kelly's organ farming operation and
putting a stop to it and we need a hard
not for this impairing our frontal lobe
again are we
bugs don't disturb me in my natural
habitat say hello to Mickey the man
lives for his team
I'd put another arrow on the chest and
doesn't mind getting his hands dirty
[Music]
he does have a slight drinking problem
though
he's passed out ah well we'll come back
to him
you know what let's go with someone a
bit more professional
it's almost crass to call him a hit man
[Music]
some might even call him an artist
here's the fasted responsible done and
dusted bad not bad if I do say so any
not everyone in London is a legendary
assassin or a super spy but everyone can
be a hero
[Music]
so get out there find the best recruits
and build your resistance
[Applause]
it's time to take back London
plunging the player into a living
breathing city teeming with unique
locales and characters has always been a
central pillar of the watchdog series so
what goes into building those worlds
here's Amanda Mundt
to tell us more my name is Amanda Mundt
I'm a Louisville artist on watchdogs
Legion at Ubisoft Toronto being a
Louisville artist I think is the coolest
job in video games because we do get the
freedom to to kind of like pick and
choose what little details we want to
depict and we get ample opportunities to
tell the stories that we want to tell in
the spaces that were assigned to I have
the capacity to hide things and you know
like small little Easter eggs in AC
unity there was a boat somewhere in the
world that was covered in cats and then
it happened again and watchdogs too and
there may or may not be something in
London that is a boat filled with cats
in some capacity I was fortunate enough
to go to e3 last year some of the people
that I was showing our demo to were from
London so no matter where I dropped them
in the city there we go oh my god this
feels like Camden this you know this
feels like suffered this feels like
Westminster when people are talking
about some detail that I've put into the
world and they're excited about it like
I feel so good as somebody who you know
builds these worlds with care I love it
[Music]
and now some news